[Music]
well the golden knights are in camp with
lots of star power they're the favorites
to win the cup this year they got a lot
of players
who are committed to making that happen
kevin martin has more on one guy who got
injured but used his rehab time to
transform himself into a
solid golden knight it's hard especially
not playing a game in 11 months and
having my first scrimmage
yesterday cody glass is finally back on
the ice in a golden knights jersey
and is slowly starting to feel more like
himself
for me i think it's just more reps more
opportunity
like i said yesterday i was kind of
timid and i wasn't really myself and
then today i was kind of more
controlling the play and making plays
that i usually make
cody underwent season ending knee
surgery back in march
and after many long months in rehab he's
back healthy
and heavy i think i'm like 15 pounds
heavier now
during his time away from the ice cody
focused on bulking up
in preparation for the upcoming season
for me i just wanted to
put my body in the best position
possible to be able to fight in those
puck battles and i knew i struggled with
that a lot last year and i was very
inconsistent so
if i can try and work on that part of my
game i think that's going to go a long
way
head coach pete devore says cody's skill
set paired with this size
is rare as an nhl centerman and is
excited to see
what he can do for years to come here in
vegas he's intriguing for me as a
centerman because
you can't find six foot two two hundred
and
fifteen pound play making uh centermen
out there that they're really hard to
find
and i think long term that's definitely
what he's gonna be here
and while the future is no doubt bright
for this 21 year old cody is focused on
putting his team in the best position to
win
now i think for me i just want to be the
best player i can possibly be
and give us a chance to produce and win
every single night
kevin martin 8 sports now all right
thanks kevin golden knight's first game
is coming up at home january 14th
against the docks it'll be interesting
to see where the players stack up in
those four lines this season